you wrote the blog post the 50-year
quest my personal Journey good title my
personal Journey with a second law of
Thermodynamics so
what is this law and what have you
understood about it in the 50-year
journey you had with it right so second
vote of thermodynamics sometimes called
law of entropy increase is this
principle of physics that says
well my version of it would be things
tend to get more random over time a
version of it that there are many
different sort of formulations of it
that are things like heat doesn't
spontaneously go from a hotter body to a
colder one when you have uh mechanical
work kind of gets dissipated into heat
you have friction and and uh kind of
when you systematically move things
eventually there'll be they'll be sort
of that the energy of of moving things
gets kind of ground down into heat
so people first sort of paid attention
to this back in the 1820s when steam
engines were a big thing and the big
question was how efficient could a steam
engine be and there's this chap called
Sadi Kano who was a a French engineer
actually his father was a a sort of
elaborate uh mathematical engineer in
France
um but he figured out these this kind of
rules for how uh kind of the the
efficiency of of the possible efficiency
of something like a steam engine and in
sort of a side part of what he did was
this idea that mechanical energy tends
to get dissipated as heat that you that
you end up going from sort of systematic
mechanical motion to this kind of random
thing well at that time nobody knew what
heat was at that time people thought
that heat was a fluid like they called
it caloric and it was a fluid that kind
of kind of was absorbed into substances
and when when heat when one hot thing
would transfer heat to a colder thing
that this fluid would flow from the hot
thing to the colder thing but anyway
then by the by the 1860s people had uh
kind of come up with this idea that
systematic energy tends to degrade into
kind of random heat that would uh that
that could then not be easily turned
back into systematic mechanical energy
um and then that that quickly became
sort of a global principle about how
things work question is why does it
happen that way so you know let's say
you have a bunch of molecules in a box
and they're arranged these molecules
arranged in a very nice sort of uh
flotiller of molecules in one corner of
the box and then what you typically
observe is that after a while these
molecules were kind of randomly arranged
and the Box question is why does that
happen and people for a long long time
tried to figure out is there from the
laws of mechanics that just determine
how these molecules that say these
molecules like hard spheres bouncing off
each other from the laws of mechanics
that describe those molecules can we
explain why it tends to be the case that
we see things that are orderly sort of
degrade into disorder we tend to see
things that uh you know you you uh you
scramble an egg you um that you know you
take something's quite ordered and you
you disorder it so to speak that's the
thing that sort of happens quite
regularly or you you put some ink into
water and it will eventually spread out
and and fill up you know fill up the
water
um but you don't see those little
particles of ink in the water all
spontaneously kind of arrange themselves
into a Big Blob and then you know jump
out of the water or something
um and uh so the question is why do
things happen in this kind of
irreversible way where you go from order
to disorder why does it happen that way
and so throughout
in the later part of the 1800s a lot of
work was done on trying to figure out
can one derive this principle this
second law of Thermodynamics this law
about the the Dynamics of heat so to
speak can one derive this from uh from
some fundamental principles of mechanics
you know in the laws of thermodynamics
the first law is basically the law of
energy energy conservation that the
total energy associated with heat plus
the total energy associated the
mechanical kinds of things plus other
kinds of energy that that total is
constant and that became a pretty well
understood principle but the the second
law of Thermodynamics was always
mysterious like why does it work this
way can it be derived from underlying
mechanical laws and so when I was uh uh
well 12 years old actually I had gotten
interested well I've been interested in
in space and things like that because I
thought that was kind of the the future
and um interesting sort of technology
and so on and for a while kind of uh you
know every deep space probe was sort of
a personal friend type thing and I knew
all all kinds of characteristics of it
and uh uh was kind of writing up all
these all these things when I was no I
don't know eight nine ten years old and
so on and then I I got interested from
being interested in kind of spacecraft I
got interested inside like how do they
work what all the instruments on them
and so on and that got me interested in
physics which was just as well because
if I'd stayed interested in space in the
you know mid to late 1960s I would have
had a long wait before you know space
really blossomed as a as an area but
adding as everything right I got
interested in physics and uh then well
the actual sort of detailed story is
when I when I kind of graduated from
elementary school at age 12. that's the
time when in England where you finish
Elementary School
um I sort of my my gift sort of I
suppose more or less for myself was I
got um this collection of um
physics books which was some college
Physics course of college physics books
and volume Five about statistical
physics it has this picture on the cover
that shows a bunch of kind of idealized
molecules sitting in one side of a box
and then it has a series of frames
showing how these molecules sort of
spread out in the box and I thought
that's pretty interesting you know what
what causes that and you know I read the
book and and the book the book actually
one of the things that was really
significant to me about that was the
book kind of claimed although I didn't
really understand what it said in detail
it kind of claimed that this sort of
principle of physics was derivable
somehow and you know other things I'd
learned about physics it was all like
it's a fact that energy is conserved
it's a fact that relativity works or
something not it's something you can
derive from some fundamental sort of it
has to be that way as a matter of kind
of of mathematics or logic or something
so it was sort of interesting to me that
there was a thing about physics that was
kind of inevitably true and derivable so
to speak and so I think that um so then
I was like this picture on this book and
I was trying to understand it and so
that was actually the first serious
program that I wrote for a computer was
probably in 1973
um written for this computer the size of
a desk program with paper tape and so on
and I tried to reproduce this picture on
the book and I didn't succeed what was
the failure mode there like what do you
mean you didn't succeed so it's a bunch
of looked like it didn't look like okay
so what happened is
okay many years later I learned how the
picture on the book was actually made
and that it was actually kind of a fake
but I didn't know that at that time
um but uh and that picture was actually
a very high-tech thing when it was made
in the beginning of the 1960s was made
on the largest supercomputer that
existed at the time and uh even so it
couldn't quite simulate the thing that
it was supposed to be simulating but
anyway I didn't know that until many
many years later so at the time it was
like you have these balls bouncing
around in this box but I was using this
computer with eight kilowatts of memory
there were 18 bit words of memory words
okay so it was um whatever 24 kilobytes
of memory
um and it had you know it had these
instructions I probably still remember
all of its machine instructions
um and it didn't really like dealing
with floating Point numbers or anything
like that and so I had to simplify this
this model of of you know particles
bouncing around a box and so I thought
well I'll put them on a grid and I'll
make you know make the things just sort
of move one square at a time and so on
and so I did the simulation and the
result was it didn't look anything like
the actual pictures on the book now many
years later in fact very recently I
realized that the thing I'd simulated
was actually an example of a whole sort
of computational irreducibility story
that I absolutely did not recognize at
the time at the time it just looked like
it did something random and it looks
wrong as opposed to it did something
random and it's super interesting that
it's random
um but I didn't recognize that at the
time and so as it was at the time I kind
of I got interested in particle physics
and I got interested in in other kinds
of physics and but this whole second
order of the Dynamics thing this idea
that sort of orderly things tend to
degrade into disorder continued to be
something I was really interested in and
I was really curious for the whole
universe why doesn't that happen all the
time like we start off at the in the Big
Bang at the beginning of the universe
was this thing that seems like it's this
very disordered collection of of stuff
and then it spontaneously forms itself
into galaxies and creates all of
complexity and order in the universe and
so I was very curious how that happens
and I but I was always kind of thinking
this is kind of somehow the second order
of thermodynamics is behind it trying to
sort of pull things back into disorder
so to speak and how was order being
created and so actually I was was
interested this is probably now 1980 I
got interested in kind of this you know
Galaxy formation and so on in the
universe I also at that time was
interested in neural networks and I was
interested in kind of how how brains
make complicated things happen and so on
okay what's the connection between the
formation of galaxies and how brains
make complicated things happen because
they're both a matter of how complicated
things come to happen
from simple Origins yeah from some sort
of known Origins I had the sense that
that what I was interested in was kind
of in all these different this sort of
different cases of where complicated
things were arising from rules and you
know I also looked at snowflakes and
things like that
um I was curious and fluid dynamics in
general I was just sort of curious about
how does complexity arise and the the
thing that I didn't you know it took me
a while to kind of realize that there
might be a general phenomenon you know I
sort of assumed oh there's galaxies over
here there's brains over here that
they're very different kinds of things
and so what happened this is probably
1981 or so I decided okay I'm I'm going
to try and make the minimal model of how
these things work yes it was sort of an
interesting experience because I had
built starting in 1979 I built my first
big computer system to think called SMP
symbolic manipulation program it's kind
of Runner of modern morpheme language
with many of the same ideas about
symbolic computation and so on
um but the thing that was very important
to me about that was you know in
building that language I'd basically
tried to figure out what were the sort
of what were the relevant computational
Primitives which have turned out to stay
with me for the last 40 something years
but it was also important because in
building a language was very different
activity from natural science which is
what I've mostly done before because in
Natural Science you start from the
phenomena of the world and you try and
figure out so how can I make sense of
the phenomena of the world
and you know kind of the world presents
you with what it has to offer so to
speak and you have to make sense of it
when you build a a you know computer
language or something you are creating
your own Primitives and then you say
come so what can you make from these
sort of the opposite way around from
what you do in Natural Science but I'd
had the experience of doing that and so
I was kind of like okay what happens if
you sort of make an artificial physics
what happens if you just make up the
rules by which systems operate and then
I was thinking you know for all these
different systems whether it was
galaxies or brains or whatever what's
the absolutely minimal model that kind
of captures the things that are
important about those systems The
computational Primitives of that system
yes and so that's what ended up with the
cellular automata where you just have a
line of black and white cells you just
have a rule that says you know given a
cell and its neighbors what will the
color of the cell be on the next step
and you just run it in a series of steps
and the sort of the ironic thing is that
seller automata are great models for
many kinds of things but galaxies and
brains are two examples where they do
very very badly they're really
irrelevant to those two is there a
connection to the second law of
Thermodynamics and cellular automata oh
yes so the things you the things you've
discovered About Cellular automata yes
okay so when I first started selling
salad automata my first papers about
them were you know the first sentence
was always about the second row of
thermodynamics it was always about how
does order manage to be produced even
though there's a second row of
thermodynamics which tries to pull
things back into disorder and I kind of
my early understanding of that had to do
with these are intrinsically
irreversible processes in cellular
automata that that form uh it's kind of
conform orderly structures even from
random initial conditions but then what
I realized this was uh well actually
it's it's one of these things where it
was a discovery that I should have made
earlier but didn't so you know I had
I've been studying so a little automata
what I did was the sort of most obvious
computer experiment you just try all the
different rules and see what they do
it's kind of like you know you've
invented a computational telescope you
just pointed at the most obvious thing
in the sky and then you just see what's
there and so I did that and I you know I
was making all these pictures of of how
cellular automata work and and I studied
these pictures I started in great detail
There Was You Can number the rules for
cellular automata and one of them is you
know rule 30. so I made a picture of
rule 30 back in 1981 or so and Rule 30
well it's and at the time I was just
like okay it's another one of these
rules I don't really it happens to be
asymmetric Left Right asymmetric and
it's like let me just consider the case
of the symmetric ones just to keep
things simpler
Etc et cetera et cetera and I just kind
of ignored it yeah and then
sort of in and actually in 1984
strangely enough I ended up having a an
early laser printer which made very high
resolution pictures and I thought I'm
going to print out an interesting you
know I want to make an interesting
picture let me take this rule 30 thing
and just make a high resolution picture
of it I did and it's it has this very
remarkable property that it's rule is
very simple you started off just from
one black cell at the top and it makes
this kind of triangular pattern but if
you look inside this pattern it looks
really random there's you know you look
at the center column of cells and you
know I studied that in great detail and
it's so far as one can tell it's
completely random and it's kind of a
little bit like digits of pi once you
you know you know the rule for
generating the digit Supply but once
you've generated them you know 3.14159
Etc they seem completely random and in
fact I put up this prize back in what
was it 2019 or something for prove
anything about the sequence basically
has anyone been able to do anything on
that uh people have sent me some things
but it's you know I don't know how these
problems are I mean I was kind of
spoiled because I have 2007 I put up a
prize for uh determining whether a
particular turing machine that I thought
was the simplest candidate for being
Universal turing machine determine
whether it is or isn't a universal
turing machine and somebody did a really
good job of of winning that prize and
proving that it was a universal turing
machine in about six months and so I you
know I didn't know whether that would be
one of these problems that was out there
for hundreds of years or whether in this
particular case young chap called Alex
Smith
um you know nailed it in six months and
so with this little 30 collection I
don't really know whether these are
things that are 100 years away from
being able to to get or whether
somebody's going to come and do
something very clever it's such a means
like for my Last Theorem essentially
rule 30 is such a simple formulation it
feels like anyone can look at it and
understand it yeah and feel like it's
within grasp
to be able to predict something to do to
direct some kind of law
right it allows you to predict something
about this middle column of rule 30.
right but you know this is yeah you
can't yeah right this is the intuitional
surprise of computational irreducibility
and so on that even though the rules are
simple you can't tell what's going to
happen and you can't prove things about
it and I think so so anyway the the the
the thing uh I I still started in 1984
or so I started realizing there's this
phenomenon that you can have very simple
rules they produce apparently random
Behavior okay so that's a little bit
like the second orthonomics because it's
like you have this simple initial
condition you can you know readily see
that it's very you know you can describe
it very easily and yet it makes this
thing that seems to be random now turns
out
thus some technical detail about the
secular thermodynamics and about the
idea of reversibility when you have a if
you have kind of a a a movie of two you
know billiard balls colliding and you
see them Collide and they bounce off and
you run that movie In Reverse you can't
tell which way was the forward direction
of time and which way was the backward
direction of time when you're just
looking at individual billiard Balls by
the time you've got a whole collection
of them you know a million of them or
something then it turns out to be the
case and this is the the sort of the The
Mystery of the second law that the
orderly thing you start with the orderly
thing and it becomes disordered and
that's the forward Direction in time and
the other way around of it starts to
sorted and becomes ordered you just
don't see that in the world
now in principle if you you know if you
sort of traced the detailed motions of
all those molecules backwards you would
be able to it it will it will the
reverse of time makes you know as you as
you go forwards in time order goes to
disorder as you go backwards in time
order goes to disorder perfectly so yes
right so the the mystery is why is it
the case that one version of the mystery
is why is it the case that you never see
something which happens to be just the
kind of disorder that you would need to
somehow evolve to order why does that
not happen why do you always just see
order goes to disorder not the other way
around
so the thing that I I kind of realized I
started realizing in the 1980s is kind
of like it's a bit like cryptography
it's kind of like you start off from
this this key that's pretty simple and
then you kind of run it and you can get
this you know complicated random mess
and uh the thing that that um
well I sort of started realizing back
then was that the second law is kind of
a a story of computational reducibility
it's a story of you know what seems you
know what what we can describe easily at
the beginning we can only describe with
a lot of computational effort at the end
okay so now we come many many years
later and um uh I was trying to sort of
uh well having done this big project to
understand fundamental physics I
realized that sort of a key aspect of
that is understanding what observers are
like and then I realized that the second
orthodynamics is the same story as a
bunch of these other cases
um it is a story of a a computationally
bounded Observer trying to observe a
computationally irreducible system so
it's a story of you know underneath the
molecules are bouncing around they're
bouncing around in this completely uh
determined way determined by rules
but the point is that that we as
computationally bounded observers can't
tell that there were these sort of
simple underlying rules to us it just
looks random and when it comes to this
question about can you prepare the
initial state so that
um you know the disordered thing is you
know how exactly the right disorder to
make something orderly a computationally
bounded Observer cannot do that we'd
have to have done all of this sort of
irreducible computation to work out very
precisely what this disordered State
what the exact right disordered state is
so that we would get this ordered thing
produced from it what does it mean to be
computationally bounded Observer
so observing a computational reducible
system so the computationally bounded is
there something formal you can say there
right so it means
okay you can you can talk about Turing
machines you can talk about
computational uh complexity Theory and
uh you know uh polynomial time
computation and things like this there
are a variety of ways to make something
more precise but I think it's more
useful the intuitive version of it is
more useful yeah which is basically just
to say that you know how much
computation are you going to do to try
and work out what's going on and the
answer is you're not allowed to do a lot
of we're not able to do a lot of
computation when we you know we've got
you know in this room there will be a
trillion trillion trillion molecules a
little bit less it's a big room
right and uh you know
at every moment you know that every
microsecond or something these molecules
molecules are colliding and that's a lot
of computation that's getting done and
the question is in our brains we do a
lot less computation every second then
the computation done by all those
molecules if there is computational
irreducibility we can't work out in
detail what all those molecules are
going to do what we can do is only a
much smaller amount of computation and
so the the second law of Thermodynamics
is this kind of interplay between the
underlying computational irreducibility
and the fact that we as preparers of
initial States or as measures of what
happens are you know are not capable of
doing that much computation so to us
another big formulation of the second
order of thermodynamics is this idea of
the law of entropy increase
the characteristic that this universe
the entropy sees to be always increasing
what does that show to you about the
evolution of
yes okay and that's very confused in the
history of thermodynamics because
entropy was first introduced by a guy
called Rudolf clausius and he did it in
terms of heat and temperature okay
subsequently it was reformulated by a
guy called Ludwig boltzmann
um and uh he formulated it in a much
more kind of combinatorial type way
but he always claimed that it was
equivalent to clausius's thing and then
in one particular simple example it is
but that connection between these two
formulations of entropy they've never
been connected I mean there's really so
okay so the more general definition of
entropy due to boltzmann is is the
following thing so you say I have a
system and has many possible
configurations molecules can be in many
different Arrangements Etc et cetera Etc
if we know something about the system
for example we know it's in a box it has
a certain pressure it has a certain
temperature we know these overall facts
about it then we say how many
microscopic configurations of the system
are possible given those overall
constraints
um and the entropy is the logarithm of
that number that's the definition and
that's the kind of the general
definition of entropy that turns out to
be useful now in Boltzmann's time he
thought these molecules can be placed
anywhere you want he didn't think a he
said oh actually we can make it a lot
simpler by having the molecules be
discrete well actually he didn't know
molecules existed right and in those in
his time 1860s and so on uh the idea
that Mata might made of discreet stuff
had been floated ever since ancient
Greek times but it had been a long time
debate about you know is math or
discrete is it continuous at the moment
at that time people mostly thought that
Mata was continuous and um it was all
confused with this question about what
heat is and people thought heat was this
fluid and um it was it was a big big
model and um the uh and this but
boltzmann said let's assume there are
discrete molecules let's even assume
they have discrete energy levels let's
say everything is discrete then we can
do sort of combinatorial mathematics and
work out how many configurations of
these things they would be in the box
and we can say we can compute the
centropy quantity but he said said but
of course it's just a fiction that these
things are discreet so he said this is
an interesting piece of History by the
way that that you know that was at that
time people didn't know molecules
existed there were other hints from from
looking at uh kind of chemistry that
there might be discrete atoms and so on
just from the combinatorics of you know
two hydrogens and one oxygen make water
you know two two amounts of hydrogen
plus one amount of oxygen together make
water things like this but it wasn't
known that discrete molecules existed
and in fact the um uh people
you know it wasn't until the beginning
of the the 20th century that Brownian
motion was the final giveaway Brown in
motion is you know you look under a
microscope of these little pieces from
pollen grains you see they're being
discreetly kicked and those kicks are
water molecules hitting them and they're
discreet
um and uh in fact it was um it was
really quite interesting history I mean
boltzmann had worked out how things
could be discreet and have basically
invented something like quantum theory
in in the 1860s and uh but he just
thought it wasn't really the way it
worked and then just a piece of physics
history because I think it's kind of
interesting in in 1900 this guy called
Max Planck who'd been a long time
thermodynamics person who was trying to
everybody was trying to prove the second
order of thermodynamics including Max
Planck and Max Planck believed that
radiation like electromagnetic radiation
somehow the interaction of that with
Mata was going to prove the second law
of thermodynamics but he had these
experiments that people had done on
black body radiation and there were
these curves and you couldn't fit the
curve based on his idea for how
radiation interacted with Mata those
curves you couldn't figure out how to
fit those curves except he noticed that
if he just did what boltzmann had done
and assumed that electromagnetic
radiation was discrete he could fit the
curves he said but you know this is just
a you know it just happens to work this
way then Einstein came along and said
well by the way you know uh the
electromagnetic field might actually be
discrete it might be made of photons and
then that explains how this all works
and that was you know in 1905 that was
that was how
um kind of that was how Quant that piece
of quantum mechanics got started kind of
interesting interesting piece of History
I didn't know until I was researching
this recently in 1904 and 1903 Einstein
wrote three different papers and uh so
you know just sort of a well-known
physics history in 1905 Einstein wrote
these three papers one introduced
relativity Theory one explained Brownian
motion and one introduced basically
photons so kind of you know kind of a a
big deal year for physics and for
Einstein but in the years before that
he'd written several papers and what
were they about they were about the
second war of thermodynamics and they
were an attempt to prove the second
order of thermodynamics and their
nonsense
and so I I had no idea that he'd done
this interesting oh neither and in fact
what he did those three papers in 1905
well not so much the relativity paper
the one on Brownian motion the one on
photons both of these were about the
story of sort of making the world
discreet
um and then he got those like that idea
from boltzmann yeah um but boltzmann
didn't think you know boltzmann kind of
died believing you know he said but he
has a quote actually you know uh you
know in the end things are going to turn
out to be discreet and I'm going to
write down what I have to say about this
because uh uh you know eventually the
stuff will be rediscovered and I want to
leave you know what I can about how
things are going to be discreet but you
know
um I think he has some quotes about how
you know one person can't stand against
the tide of history in um uh in saying
that you know matter is discrete so so
he stopped by his guns it doesn't matter
is discrete yes he did and and the you
know what's interesting about this is uh
at the time everybody including Einstein
kind of assumed that space was probably
going to end up being discreet too but
that didn't work out technically because
it wasn't consistent with relativity
Theory it didn't seem to be and so then
in the history of physics even though
people had determined that Mata was
discrete electoral magnetic field was
discrete space was a holdout of not
being discreet and in fact Einstein 1916
has this nice letter he wrote where he
says in the end it will turn out space
is discrete but we don't have the
mathematical tools necessary to figure
out how that works yet
and so you know I think it's kind of
cool that 100 years later we do yes for
you you're pretty pretty sure that at
every layer of reality it's discrete
right and that space is discreet and
that uh the I mean and in fact one of
the things I realized recently is this
kind of theory of heat that um uh
that the um you know that heat is really
this continuous fluid
um it's it's kind of like uh the the you
know the caloric theory of heat which
turns out to be completely wrong because
actually heat is the motion of a
discrete molecules unless you know there
are discrete molecules it's hard to
understand what heat could possibly be
well you know I think space is is
discrete and the question is kind of
what's the analog of the mistake that
was made with caloric
in the case of space and so I'm my my
current guess is that dark matter is as
I've my little sort of aphorism of the
of the last few months has been you know
dark matter is the caloric of our time
that is it will turn out the dark matter
is a feature of space and it is not a
bunch of particles you know at the time
when when people were talking about heat
they knew about fluids and they said
well heat must just be another kind of
fluid because that's what they knew
about yes but now people know about
particles and so they say well what's
dark matter it's not it's not it just
must be particles so what could dark
matter be as a feature of space Oh I
don't know yet all right um I mean I
think the the thing I'm really one of
the things I'm hoping to be able to do
is to find the analog of brown in Motion
in space so in other words Brown in
motion was was seeing down to the level
of an effect from Individual molecules
and so in the case of space you know
most of the things the things we see
about space so far just everything seems
continuous Brownian motion have been
discovered in the 1830s and it was only
identified what it was what it was the
the results of bias uh smallchowski and
Einstein at the beginning of the 20th
century and you know Dark Matter was was
discovered that phenomenon was
discovered 100 years ago
um you know the rotation curves of
galaxies don't follow the Luminous
matter that was discovered 100 years ago
and I think you know that I I wouldn't
be surprised if there isn't an effect
that we already know about that is kind
of the analog of brown in motion that
reveals the discreetness of space and in
fact we're beginning to have some
guesses we have some some evidence that
black hole mergers work differently when
there's discrete space and there may be
things that you can see in gravitational
wave signatures and things associated
with the discreetness of space but this
is kind of uh for me it's kind of it's
kind of interesting to see this sort of
recapitulation of the history of physics
where people you know vehemently say you
know matter is continuous
electromagnetic field is continuous and
turns out it isn't true and then they
say space is continuous But but so you
know entropy is the number of states of
the system consistent with some
constraint yes and the the thing is that
if you have if you know in great detail
the position of every molecule in the
gas
the entropy is is always zero because
there's only one possible State the the
configuration of molecules and the gas
the molecules bounce around they have a
certain rule for bouncing around there's
just one state of the gas evolves to one
state of the gas and so on but it's only
if you don't know in detail where all
the molecules are that you can say well
the entropy increases because the things
we do know about the molecules there are
more possible microscopic states of the
system consistent with what we do know
about where the molecules are and so the
question of whether
um so people this sort of paradox in a
sense of oh if we knew where all the
molecules were the entropy wouldn't
increase there was this idea introduced
by by Gibbs in the early 20th century
well actually the very beginning of the
20th century as a physics Professor an
American physics Professor was sort of
the first distinguished American physics
Professor um at Yale
um and he he introduced reduce this idea
of course graining this idea that well
you know these molecules have a detail
where they're bouncing around but we can
only observe a coarse grained version of
that but the confusion has been nobody
knew what a valid course screening would
be so nobody knew that whether you could
have the score screening that very
carefully was sculpted in just such a
way that it would notice that the
particular configurations that you could
get from the simple initial condition
you know they fit into this coarse
graining and the course graining very
carefully observes that why can't you do
that kind of very detailed precise
course screening the answer is because
if you are a computationally bounded
Observer and the underlying Dynamics is
computationally irreducible that's
that's what defines possible core
screenings is what a computationally
bounded Observer can do and it's the
it's the fact that a computationally
bounded Observer uh is is forced to look
only at this kind of coarse grained
version of what the system is doing
that's why and and because the what's
what's going on underneath is it's kind
of filling out this this the the
different possible you're ending up with
something where
the sort of underlying computational
irreducibility is uh
your if if all you can see is what the
coarse grained result is with copy with
a sort of computationally bounded
observation then inevitably there are
many possible underlying configurations
that are consistent with that just to
clarify basically any Observer that
exists inside the universe
is going to be computationally bounded
no any Observer like us I don't know I
can't say like us what do you mean what
do you mean like us well
humans with finite Minds you're
including the tools of science yeah yeah
I mean and and as we you know we have
more precise and by the way there are
little sort of microscopic violations of
the second order of thermodynamics that
you can start to have when you have more
precise measurements of where precisely
molecules are but for uh for a large
scale when you have enough molecules we
don't have you know we're not tracing
all those molecules and we just don't
have the computational resources to do
that and it wouldn't be uh you know I
think the the to imagine what an
observer who is not computationally
bounded would be like
it's an interesting thing because okay
so what does computational boundedness
mean among other things it means we
conclude that definite things happen we
go we take all this complexity of the
world and we make a decision we're going
to turn left or turn right and that is
kind of reducing all this kind of uh
detail into we're observing it we're
we're sort of crushing it down to this
this one thing yeah and and that if we
didn't do that
uh we wouldn't we wouldn't have all this
sort of symbolic structure that we build
up that lets us think things through
with our finite Minds we'd be instead
you know we'd be just we'd be sort of
one with the universe yeah so content
to not simplify yes if we didn't
simplify then we wouldn't be like us we
would be like the universe like the the
intrinsic universe but not having
experiences like the experiences we have
where we for example conclude that
definite things happen we you know we we
sort of have this this uh uh notion of
being able to make make sort of
narrative statements yeah I wonder if
it's just like you imagined as a thought
experiment what it's like to be a
computer I wonder if it's possible to
try to begin to imagine what it's like
to be an unbounded computational
well okay so here's here's how that I
think plays out vibrations suck yeah so
I mean in this we talk about this
rouliad the space of all possible
computation yes and this idea of you
know being at a certain place in the
rouliad which corresponds to sort of a
certain way of of rep of a certain set
of computations that you're representing
things in terms of okay so as you expand
out in the rouliad as you kind of
Encompass more possible views of the
universe as you Encompass more possible
kinds of computations that you can do
eventually you might say that's a real
win you know we're colonizing the
rouliad we're we're we're building out
more paradigms about how to think about
things and eventually you might say we
we won all the way we managed to
colonize the whole Riyadh okay here's
the problem with that the problem is
that the notion of existence coherent
existence
requires some kind of specialization by
the time you are the whole rouliad by
the time you cover the whole rouliad in
no useful sense do you coherently exist
so in other words in inches the notion
of existence the notion of what we think
of as as definite existence requires
this kind of specialization requires
this kind of idea that we are we are not
all possible things we are the a
particular set of things and that's kind
of how we uh that that's kind of what
what makes us have a coherent existence
if we were spread throughout the rouliad
we would not there would be no coherence
to the way that we work we would work in
all possible ways and that wouldn't be
kind of a notion of identity we wouldn't
have this notion of kind of uh uh of of
of coherent identity
I am geographically located somewhere
exactly precisely in the rouliad
therefore I am
physical space you're in a certain place
in real space and if if you uh if you
are sufficiently spread out you are no
longer coherent and you no longer have I
mean in in the in our perception of what
it means to exist and to have experience
it doesn't happen now so therefore so to
exist means to be computationally bonded
I think so to exist in the way that we
think of ourselves as existing yes the
very active existence is like operating
in this place that's computationally
reducible so this is just giant mess of
things going on that you can't possibly
predict
but nevertheless because of your
limitations
you have an imperative of like what is
it an imperative or a skill set to
simplify or an ignorance a sufficient
love okay so the thing which is not
obvious is that you are taking a slice
of all this complexity just like we have
all of these molecules bouncing around
in the room but all we notice is you
know the the the the kind of the flow of
the air or the pressure of the air we're
just noticing these particular things
and the the big interesting thing is
that there are rules there are laws that
govern those big things that we we
observe yeah so it's not obvious it's
amazing because it doesn't feel like
it's a slice yeah well right not a slice
well it's like uh it's like an
abstraction yes but I mean the fact that
the gas laws work that we can describe
pressure volume Etc et cetera et cetera
we don't have to go down to the level of
talking about individual molecules that
is a non-trivial fact and and here's the
thing that I sort of exciting thing as
far as I'm concerned the fact that there
are certain aspects of the universe so
you know we think space is made
ultimately these atoms of space and
these typographs and so on and we think
that uh but we nevertheless perceive the
universe at a large scale to be like
continuous space and so on
um we uh in quantum mechanics we think
that there are these many threads of
time these many threads of History yet
we kind of span so so you know in in
quantum mechanics in our models of
physics there are these time is not a
single thread time breaks into many
threads they Branch they merge and but
we we are part of that branching merging
Universe right and so our brains are
also branching and merging and so when
we perceive the universe we are
branching brains perceiving a branching
Universe yeah and so the fact that the
claim that we exp we believe that we are
persistent in time we have this single
thread of experience that's the
statement that somehow we managed to
aggregate together those separate
threads of time that are separated in in
the operation of in the fundamental
operation of the universe so just as in
space we're averaging over some big
region of space and we're looking at
many many of the aggregate effects of
many atoms of space so similarly in what
we call branchial space the space of
these these Quantum branches we are
effectively averaging over many
different branches of possible of
histories of the universe and so in in
thermodynamics we're averaging over many
configurations of you know many many
possible positions of molecules yeah so
what what we see here is so the question
is when you do that averaging for space
What are the aggregate laws of space
when you do that averaging of a
branchial space What are the aggregate
laws a branchial space when you do that
averaging over the molecules and so on
what are the aggregate laws you get and
this is this is the thing that I I think
is just amazingly amazingly neat that
there are aggregate laws at all well yes
but the question is what are those
aggregate laws so the answer is for
space the aggregate laws Einstein's
equations for Gravity for the structure
of space-time for branchial space the
aggregate laws of the laws of quantum
mechanics and for uh the case of of
molecules and things the aggregate laws
are basically the second law of
thermodynamics
and so the um though that's the and the
things that follow from the second world
of thermodynamics and so what that means
is that the three great theories of 20th
century physics which are basically
General authority of the theory of
gravity uh quantum mechanics and
statistical mechanics which is what kind
of grows out of the second law of
Thermodynamics all three of the great
theories of 20th century physics are the
result of this interplay between
computational irreducibility and the
computational boundedness of observers
and you know for me this is really neat
because it means that all three of these
laws are derivable so we used to think
that for example Einstein's equations
were just sort of a wheel in feature of
our universe that they could be the
universe might be that way it might not
be that way quantum mechanics is just
like well it just happens to be that way
and the second law people kind of
thought well maybe it is derivable okay
what turns out to be the case is that
all three of the fundamental principles
of physics are derivable but they're not
derivable just from mathematics they
require or just from some kind of
logical computation they require one
more thing they require that the
Observer that the thing that is sampling
the way the universe works is an
observer who has these characteristics
of computational boundedness of belief
and persistence and time and so that
that means that it is the nature of the
Observer
you know the rough nature of the
Observer not the details of oh we got
two eyes and we've observed photons of
this frequency and so on uh but the the
the the the kind of the very coarse
features of the Observer
um then imply these very precise facts
about physics and it's it's I think it's
amazing so if we just look at the actual
experience of the Observer that we
experience this reality it seems real to
us
and you're saying because of our bonded
nature it's actually all an illusion
it's a simplification yeah it's a
simplification right what's what's so
you don't think a simplification is an
illusion
no I mean it's it's well I don't know I
mean what underneath
uh okay that's an interesting question
um what's real and that relates to the
whole question of why does the universe
exist and um you know what is the
difference between reality and a mere
representation of what's going on yes we
experience the representation yes but
the the question of so so one question
is uh you know why is there a thing
which we can experience that way
and the answer is
because this rouliad object which is
this entangled limit of all possible
computations there is no choice about it
it has to exist it has to there has to
be such a thing it is in in the same
sense that you know two plus two if you
define what two is and you plot pluses
and so on two plus two has to equal four
similarly this really add this limit of
all possible computations just has to be
a thing you that is once you have the
idea of computation you inevitably have
the rule yeah you're gonna have to have
a rule yeah yeah right and and what's
important about it there's just one of
it it's it's it's just this unique
object and that unique object
necessarily exists and then the question
is what uh and then we
uh once once you know that we are sort
of embedded in that and taking samples
of it that it's sort of inevitable that
there is this thing that we can perceive
that is you know the the our perception
of kind of physical reality
necessarily is that way given that we
are observers with the characteristics
we have so in other words the fact that
the fact that the Universe exists is
it's actually it's almost like it's you
know to think about it almost
theologically so to speak and I I really
it's it's funny because a lot of the
questions about the existence of the
universe and so on they they transcend
what kind of the science of the last few
hundred years has really been concerned
with the science of the last few hundred
years hasn't thought it could talk about
questions like that yeah
um and uh but I think it's kind of and
so a lot of the kind of arguments of you
know does God exist you know is it
obvious that I think it in some sense in
some representation it's sort of more
more obvious that uh that something sort
of bigger than us exists than that we
exist and we are you know our existence
and as observers the way we are is sort
of a contingent thing about the universe
and it's more inevitable that the whole
the whole universe kind of the whole set
of all possibilities
exists but but this question about you
know is is it real or is it an illusion
you know all we know is our experience
and so the fact that well our experience
is this absolutely microscopic piece of
sample of the rouliad and we're
um and and you know there's this this
point about you know we might sample
more and more of the rouliad we might
learn more and more about we might learn
you know like like different areas of
physics like Quantum Mechanics for
example the fact that it it was
discovered I think is closely related to
the fact that electronic amplifiers were
invented that allowed you to take a
small effect and amplify it up which
hadn't been possible before you know
microscopes have been invented that
magnify things and so on but they're you
know having a very small effect and
being able to magnify it was sort of a
new thing that allowed one to see a
different sort of aspect of the universe
and let one discover this kind of thing
so you know we can expect that in the
rouliad they're an infinite collection
of new things we can discover there's
there's in fact computational energy
ability kind of guarantees that there
will be an infinite collection of kind
of you know pockets of reducibility that
can be discovered
boy would it be fun to take a walk down
the Wooly ad and see what kind of stuff
we find there